Hello!
I am not Hank.
I am Nicole and I’m usually a behind-the-scenes
member of the Crash Course staff,
but for the next year
I will be here, teaching you about sociology.
We’ve covered a lot of things here at Crash
Course and sociology has kind of been lurking
about throughout all of them.
Sociology is the study of people and society and
that includes a really broad range of topics –
everything from social and economic
inequalities to marriage and family formation
to political and religious institutions.
Sociologists answer questions like,
“What is class and why does almost every
American seem to think that they’re middle class?”
or “How do different political institutions
change the cultural norms of a society?”
or “Why do some societies end up with more
unequal outcomes than other societies?”
Sociology is the study of how we form societies
and how those societies form us as individuals.
While a world history class might tell you about
how different races and ethnicities have been
discriminated against in the past and present,
sociology tells us how we’ve constructed
racial and ethnic groups and why social
inequalities exist along racial lines.
An economist might create models of how
the wage an individual is offered by a firm
affects their well-being,
whereas a sociologist might look at how the
neighborhoods and communities that a person
grows up in affects their well-being.
And understanding these questions can help
us make big decisions about the kind of world
that we want to live in
and the kind of people that we want to be
in that world.
So I hope you’ll join me over the next
year as we explore all of this and more in
Crash Course Sociology.